heute hat ja sich so ein zitat von karl
lauterbach besser gesagt seines
ministeriums in die öffentliche debatte
geschlichen das wie ich finde in einem
skandal gleich kommt oder zumindest
absolut unglaubliches denn auf eine
anfrage an das ministerium geantwortet
die
intensivstationen in deutschland war nie
überlastet was ich dachte das ist der
grund für all diese maßnahmen
nein sie waren überlastet weder in den
regionen natürlich ein paar wurden 100
mehr etwas mehr als 100 patienten
verlegt in ein anderes krankenhaus das
kommt ja wenn man logistik planen kann
mal vor aber diese apokalypse wir müssen
jetzt handeln wir müssen jetzt schulen
schließen wir müssen in den lokalen wir
müssen ausgangssperren machen weil in
unseren krankenhäusern ereignen sich
furchtbare szenen die intensivstationen
sind überlastet ich höre alle politiker
ist ein fan karl lauterbach da war noch
nicht minister höre ich es sagen das
wird kommen das wird kommen und so oder
dabei geguckt das wird kommen mit dieser
rhetorik hat er sozusagen
begründete grundrechts einschränkungen
größeren ausmaßes zu legitimieren und
die politik ist voll darauf eingestiegen
und jetzt stellt sich heraus das
hauptargument wir sind fallen die
intensivstationen waren überlastet und
wahrscheinlich wenn man genau hinschaut
und das haben wir getan waren sie auch
nur selten oder nie in der nähe
überlastet zu sein und die zu etwas ganz
schönes sagen wenn man vielleicht die
zeit genutzt die intensivstation besser
auszustatten mit menschen und material
dann wäre dieses problem doch viel
weiter von uns weg gerückt und was
bedeutet das jetzt lasst uns eine kleine
zusammenfassung wir wissen jetzt masten
bringen nicht so viel wie man gedacht
lockt da uns haben überhaupt nichts
gebracht die intensivstationen waren
überlastet aber wir haben es geschafft
und ganze ist ja ein ganzes land
teilweise lahmzulegen mit deren folgen
ökonomische psychologische
gesellschaftliche
meine sorge ist dass sich am ende
herausstellt es war gar nicht corona
schuld an all den sondern überzogene
unangemessene unverhältnismäßige
maßnahmen und wenn diese hypothese zu
treffen dann ist die schlimmste longo
wird folge ein eklatanter
glaubwürdigkeitsverlust der politik und
wenn ich heute genau zugehört habt wie
die zauderer und hasenfüße die chance
vertan haben sofort alles zu öffnen
sondern sich wieder noch einige schritte
und hier noch ein schritt und wie sie
dann sich austauschen über detail
probleme das alles nimmt mich nicht ein
als fan
des föderalismus und der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dabei bin
ich eigentlich großer fan der demokratie
ja also ich muss da wirklich kann da nur
zustimmen und ich war auch etwas
erstaunt über luft aus so überlassen
weil das interessante ist wir hatten das
im letzten herbst schon mal herr spahn
als gesundheitsminister hat einen
wissenschaftlichen beirat extra
eingesetzt sie sollten sich auf angriff
fahren denn in der welle davor also da
waren ja die zahlen tatsächlich auch
noch mal höher als jetzt im herbst ohne
impfung immerhin das erste corona jahr
waren da liegt die intensivstation und
die krankenhäuser jemals überlastet und
es war tatsächlich so ich glaube im
letzten april ist das rausgekommen ganz
amtlich bestätigt haben sie gesagt na ja
die waren nicht überlastet und jetzt
bestätigt lauterbach das auch natürlich
heißt das nicht dass nicht in den
krankenhäusern trotzdem an vielen
stellen ziemlich schlimme zustände waren
aber das ist etwas das haben wir auch
pflegerinnen und pfleger als sie das
haben wir regelmäßig im winter immer
wieder gehabt und ich habe auch all die
presse mitteilte presse berichte gelesen
da stand dann auch da wurde also
verzweifelt wurden dann intensiv
patienten verlegt in andere bundesländer
das waren alles berichte aus der zeit
vor corona zum beispiel aus dieser
grippewelle 2017 2018 da hatten wir das
massenhaft das intensivstation voll
waren dass menschen verlegt werden
mussten das übrigens auch operationen
verschoben werden mussten das ist nichts
neues und ich sage nicht dass das was
schön es ist also ich finde man sollte
was dagegen tun aber das was man dagegen
tun kann ist nicht das land immer wieder
in den lotter und zu schicken und ich
habe mir auch immer wieder diese zahlen
auch beim diw also da wird ja immer so
diese ganze reihe der chor der der
intensivpatienten
und das erstaunliche ist die hat keine
großen ausschläge also das ist immer
relativ konstant
das gleiche und es gibt sogar eine
analyse dass die krankenhäuser im jahr
2020 und 2021 übrigens auch im
durchschnitt kann man immer sagen der
durchschnitt ist eben nicht die spitze
aber im durchschnitt deutlich weniger
belegung hatten als in allen jahren
davor also die sollen wir die gesamtzahl
der patienten ist rückläufig gewesen und
da kann man sagen gut 2020 gab es ja
noch politische auflagen dass sie frei
halten mussten zwar sind jetzt wurde es
21 gab es das aber nicht mehr also warum
sinken eigentlich die belegungen in den
krankenhäusern und gleichzeitig wird
überlastung des gesundheitssystems um
hauptargument passiver grundrechte
einschränkung also das passt einfach
nicht zusammen der coole darauf waren
sie vermutlich werden ja ich ärgere mich
darüber warum herr lauterbach so was
sagt und mein stück na ja ich würde das
gerne aufgeklärt als ich das letzte mal
geschaut habe da sind leute von einem
bundesland ins andere geflogen mit mit
der bundeswehr wir haben patienten 315
glaube ich meine es in
japan als auch darüber dass
sie nun als auch echtes interesse an zu
sehen dass leute von dem 1 erst nach ein
anderer
große krankenhäuser bei mir im wahlkreis
wo die leute gesagt haben wir haben
große probleme auf der intensivstation
bitte tu was ja bitte setzt euch dafür
ein dass wir corona in den griff kriegen
habe ich immer gesagt na ja es wäre ganz
gut wenn wir in der impfung hätten mit
der wir flächen weg dafür sorgen können
dass es keine freiheitseinschränkung
braucht und so lange wir nicht genug
leute geimpft haben brauchte ist eben
leider auch einschränkungen wo ich der
meinung bin der staat massiv über das
ziel hinaus geschossen ist wir haben
teilweise das parlament entmachtet mit
der epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite gut dass wir das hinter uns
gebracht haben wir haben teilweise auf
ausgangs beschränkungen gesetzt also die
bewegungsfreiheit von leuten
eingeschränkt sich draußen an der
frischen luft nachts einfach sportlich
zu betätigen absurd das hätten wir nicht
machen dürfen das war ein fehler ich bin
jetzt im nachhinein die begründung
geändert wird dann zerstört das
vertrauen und das sollte lauterbach klar
wie ist die lage aktuell macht die
politik jetzt gerade alles richtig ist
wurde jetzt gerade gelobt wie jetzt die
wege sind der entscheidung mich würde
freilich noch mal interessieren wie hat
er
das problem an dieser intensivbetten
zählerei ist dass es ein dynamisches
intensivbetten manager und gibt wir
hatten anfang dezember etwa 5000
intensivbetten im mitte februar hatten
über 2.700 etwa die werden abgebaut von
den krankenhäusern und wieder
aufgestockt das kann man das kann man da
wird selbst das so wie soll ich sagen na
ja so ist das aber ja da wir hätten die
5000 und als dann sozusagen carola
richtig über uns weggefegt das waren sie
noch 2007
zwischendurch gab es noch einen viel
komplizierteren mechanismus hat jens
spahn für solche freigehaltenen betten
sonderprämien ausgelobt dann grassierten
auf einmal die intensivbetten weil
natürlich die krankenhäuser wo es was zu
holen gibt die bettenzahlen aufstocken
ist alles schon ist alles dokumentiert
aber die intensivbetten zahl war
eigentlich nie eine maßzahl das problem
an der jetzigen politik ist glaube ich
dass man nicht weiß wie man von dem baum
runterkommt auf dem man sitzt und bei
habe ich manchmal den eindruck er ist
noch ein bisschen in der opposition wir
müssen jetzt langsam wieder ein bisschen
einschwören na ja dann immer noch drei
unterschiedliche parteien in der ampel
regierung und das soll auch sonst viel
freude absolut muss auch erkennbar
bleiben in der koalition das regieren
will dann muss man diesen schritt gehen
aber natürlich gibt es unterschiedliche
meinungen seiner kollektion sind also
kubicki ich bin manchmal team kubicki
wenn es zum beispiel darum den ausgangs
beschränkungen zu verhindern ich bin
aber der meinung wenn wir es nicht
schaffen im nächsten herbst winter eine
ausreichende impfquote zu haben dann
braucht man als mitarbeiterin christa
kriegen würde ja eindeutig sagen
man maßnahmen kohle müssen jetzt alle
weg wenn jetzt die begründung also ich
meine das muss man sich mal vorstellen
es war nie überlastet dann sich heute
das sind einer meinung dass es nicht
also ich habe informationen aus dem
gesundheitssystem was normale leute die
da arbeiten hier erzählt und die sagen
die situation war jetzt schlimmer als in
den normalen grippewellen also dass die
ernsthaft sagen dass corona auf den
intensivstationen genauso wie in der
gruppe das legt sich überhaupt nicht
wird der krankheitsverlauf waren
arbeiter ist die überlastung da war dass
die intensivstation voll waren dass die
pfleger am rande ihrer kräfte waren dass
leute verlegt werden mussten das hatten
wir vor kronen zeitung habe ich auch mal
nachricht auch schon vor ein paar jahren
darauf hingewiesen das ist schlimm wird
für die aktion da muss was nicht das ist
aber corona hat die situation auf der
intensivstation zusätzlich belastet so
habe ich es wahrgenommen die maßnahmen
die dann unternommen worden sind die
muss man aber eng begründen und ich habe
das gefühl mitunter sind plötzlich
diejenigen rechtfertigungsbedarf dich ja
die maßnahmen aufheben wollen und
diejenigen die immer was neues
verlängern verlängern wollen die
tauschen sozusagen die gründe und
argumente stellt das kann nicht sein
die haben genau aber die haben
angesichts der knappen betten die herr
schuler beschrieben hat ja genau den
ausschlag gegeben dass da wieder verlegt
werden musste na ja gut aber man hat
eben auch betten abgebaut also man hat
ja allein im letzten jahr über 5000
betten abgebaut wegen des
pflegenotstands also nicht einfach so
aber trotzdem waren die weniger
vorhanden nachdem man vorher mit sehr
viel milliarden öffentlichen geld
zusätzliche betten gesponsert hat die
dann in den kellern standen und wir
haben ja zum beispiel die situation
selbst im herbst in der del tabelle wo
nun sehr viel mehr menschen auch in die
intensivstation mussten als jetzt unter
omikron waren in der spitze 4900
menschen in denen intensivstation mit
corona und wenn ich dann sehe dass 5000
betten weniger zur verfügung stehen muss
man ja sagen die korona patienten auch
nur bei gleichbleibenden kapazitäten
wären gar nicht ins gewicht gefallen und
ein staat der sich immer darauf bezieht
dass er die überlastung des
gesundheitswesens verhindern muss der
muss doch verdammt noch mal in die
pflicht genommen werden zumindest etwas
dagegen zu tun dass die belastungsgrenze
immer weiter absinkt also das muss doch
teil seiner aufgabe sein und nicht immer
nur zu sagen wir müssen jetzt die
gesellschaft eine schnelle politische
forderung ändert doch nichts an der
tatsache dass krebsoperationen und
vorsorgeuntersuchungen verschoben werden
mussten weil man über corona die
kapazitäten nicht mehr hat also mussten
eben oftmals gar nicht verschoben werden
weil die krankenhäuser leer waren wir
hatten das in berlin gleich in der
ersten welle schon dass die auslastung
eben nicht so hoch war und es wurden
bauchspeicheldrüsen op s knie-op es
verschoben die man gut hätte machen
können selbst solche op s wo man am
abend wieder nach hause geht hätten ja
jetzt nicht im operationssaal den ganzen
tag gebunden allein aus also dann wurde
alles darauf angewiesen dass mir die
leute aus den krankenhäusern da die
wahrheit sagen er ist will ich glaube
mir von kluge bemerkung gemacht dass das
ist natürlich solche krankenhäuser und
solche gang häuser gibt und wir uns
immer leicht tun wenn man immer genau
das krankenhaus mit seinen erzählungen
das zur eigenen reisepass
deswegen bin ich aber das ist ja jetzt
wird es nichts diese aussage von
lauterbach das ist eine offizielle
aussage des bundesgesundheitsministerium
auf eine anfrage wenn ich es richtig im
kopf von herrn kubik genau also das
bedeutet das ist das ist jetzt also wenn
man überhaupt dann was glauben kann dann
würden sagen dann dieses zahlenwerk
glaube ich und das finde ich schon er
ist es taten aber da sagt dass er danach
hat er sagt
ja unser segensreiches wirken hat ja
dazu geführt dass es dass sie nie
ausgelastet waren aus der falle kommt
man nicht raus das werden wir nie
beweisen können ja ich wertschätze
dieses argument auch denke mir dann aber
es kommt ein zweites argument übrigens
immer na ja aber die ganze welt hat ja
quasi locker und so weiter verhängt also
so verrückt war ja deutschland da nicht
aufnehmen auf einem sonderweg aber es
gibt trotzdem den deutschen weg der
wirkt holpriger langsamer schlechter
daten passiert sondern eher so gefühlt
also gefühlte politik statt daten
passierte politik übrigens keinen
vorwurf weil es gibt keine daten keine
gescheiten die gesundheitsämter faxen
alles mögliche trifft erst viel später
ein als man es braucht da sind andere
länder uns voraus ich finde nur die
konsequenz aus einer solchen aussage des
gesundheitsministeriums muss ja sein
jetzt sofort alle maßnahmen weg jetzt
sofort auch diese verfluchte masken
pflicht weg jetzt sofort rückzug bei
impfpflicht dass ich mir heute anhören
was ich habe schon immer gesagt aber es
regt mich das sagt mir ich hätte am
meisten auf das der schuld sich hinsetzt
und ich weiß mich da mit den 16
ministerpräsidenten einig und jetzt
werden wir dafür eine mehrheit zu
bekommen ich wünsche mir so sehr dass
keine mehrheit im bundestag gibt für die
allgemein so schnell hat das nicht
gesagt
das stimmt hat lancom gesprochen instanz
war heute wieder oder immer muss ich zur
kur berge sie will dem einzug halten wer
so eine geile performance bei putin
hatte der ist dann wenn er in diesem
kleinen teilchen monatsraten dass das
core ist passiert wenn möglich mit der
länge der tische aber wir setzen die
auch in einer stadt wo man ja
landtagswahlen schätzt insofern sind ist
das zahlen corona jetzt auch nicht
verblüffen